[Music]
today I want to share a story about my
name see a little confusion out there
but I just think this is a good way to
get to know me but little bit better
needless to say I am NOT an expert in
Hindu mythology but some stories I could
tell me the lure was once the son of a
king whose second wife refused to
countenance letting him sit on his lap
as someone who was I think an ardent
devotee of the god Vishnu who was
refused to abide by this injustice and
marshaled all of his perseverance
devotion steadfastness
and fearlessness to enter a six-month
meditative trance with access to neither
food nor water the austerity of this
meditation shook the heavens and Vishnu
came down to us throughout the stated
desire however having already renounced
both family and all desires through
accountant cells unable to utter a word
touched
Vishnu decree that Google could maybe
become a celestial body visible to all
the world
forevermore how terrible isn't it how
many of you disconnected Rohan how many
how many how many wanted to disconnect
the night were ones ourselves a lot of
us make a few simple mistakes like the
ones that riddle the story I just said
and these mistakes have two horrible
impacts they reduce the credibility of
both our message and us as individuals
that's why Christina choose fauna and
myself want to talk to you about
powerful words today and specifically we
want to share three strategies that can
help make each of us better seekers the
first keep it simple the second get
points and finally be confident be
direct to illustrate the power of the
use admittedly extremely simple
techniques let me redo the story I just
share people offer asked me what my name
means according to Indian tradition
there was once a child who creates OTP
he will eternally is remembered as the
North Star or Zulu adhara and with that
I handed over to the Sina the talk about
simplicity
so it's dream of a saying the first rule
of powerful speaking is simplicity keep
it simple
often when we're nervous or if we're
feeling insecure about a topic we're
tempted to use really big words because
we think it will make us sound smart I'm
here to tell you to resist that urge and
we'll start with a video of Joey
Tribbiani you know what you're working
on Oh
Monica and Chandler's recommendation I
want it to sound smart but I don't know
any big words or anything so I won't use
your thesaurus what'd I just say what
here you are your highlight the word you
want to change go under tools and the
thesaurus generates it gives gives a
whole list of choices you can pick the
word that sounds smartest god that's
great I'm smart
not all I'm brainy right clever I love
this today
look out ladies joey tribbiani's got the
whole package
we've all been here we're tempted to do
this because you want to sound smart we
want to be credible but actually the
experts all agree that simple short
words are much more powerful for example
if you want to use the word utilize how
about just use or if you find yourself
wanting to say commence consider start
this applies for so many words think of
every time you wanted to say a fist or
facilitate how about just help easier
words are much easier for you to say and
so you end up coming across much more
polished and you'll get to your speech
in a much better way but also easier
words are easier for your audience to
understand so I'll use an example from
because politicians have a vested
interest in you understanding what
they're saying and feeling like they're
credible and smart and being persuaded
and yes I find that politicians
especially get into this mess so I'll
share a quote by John Kerry we need a
new approach to national security
a bold progressive internationalism that
stands in stark contrast to the too
often belligerent and myopic
unilateralism of the Bush administration
I think I know what he's talking about
but that was a little bit of a riddle to
say and I also end up a little bit too
cute let's compare this with Barack
Obama also talking about foreign
policies since World War two some of our
most costly mistakes came not from
restraint but from our willingness to
rush into military adventures without
thinking through the consequences so
much better so simple words there's
easier to stay much easier for your
audience to understand but they also
make you sound more credible if you
think about the best technical speeches
you've ever heard
they were probably great because the
speaker was able to distill the idea
into a
Kord simple message when you use big
words you just end up sounding
pretentious so to end the point on
simplicity we'll go back to Joey for a
minute just understand some of the words
a little too sophisticated for you it
doesn't make any sense well of course it
does it's smart
I used a thesaurus on every word yep all
right what was that sentence originally
oh they are warm nice people with big
hearts and that became their humid pre
possessing Homo sapiens with full-sized
aortic pump simply don't do this keep it
simple and now Jules is going to walk us
through rule number two so rule number
two is brevity get to the point now
before we can learn how we can get to
the point the first step is to recognize
our tendencies so many of us have three
tendencies that keep us from being brief
the first tendency is over explain how
many of you have remember the movie
clueless Wow
well for those of you who don't remember
I haven't seen it it's a light-hearted
comedy about a high school girl who
mostly ditzy but sometimes brilliant
when the star was asked what clueless is
about this was what she said I think
that the film RunAs was very deep I
think it was deep in a way that it was
very light I don't like nothing to come
from a very deep place in a shoe like
this
to be fair Alicia Silverstone at that
time was only 18 years old but how many
times have we been in the audience and
seeing people over explain what they
wanted to say second tendency to
recognize that all of us passed under
preparing and I'm sure this rings true
this couple of weeks that final
assignments are piling up for all of us
so I wanted to share a short clip
actually from 1988 about a politician
was laughably underprepared what he did
since we can't access it right now was
that he essentially said that we're in
this era
oh no wait wait wait we're not in this
year we fought in World War two in the
century oh wait wait wait we didn't
actually fight in World War two and it
was last century that we lived in it was
extremely convoluted and this is a
politician who are standing up in front
of the press corps it couldn't even show
that we had properly prepared for this
interview the third tendency is for us
to miss the point I think many of us
when we're having to answer off-the-cuff
tend to ramble think aloud and end up
missing the point and the video that I
was going to show perhaps would have
been something that many of us
especially those who are Americans would
remember it's the video by John Kerry
when he uttered the difficult the
memorable words binders of women so he
will recall he was asked in the 2012
presidential debate about how he wanted
to make sure that women could have an
equal place in the workplace he rambled
he talked about how he had sculpted for
all many women to be part of the
interview process and he ended up with
and then I had a
binder full of women completely missing
the point
and being meand throughout the 2012
presidential election but now that we
know our three tendencies what do we
need to do in order to be briefed and
get to the point so it's just three
simple steps first met your message
remember the forest step back and see
the forest for the trees what is the
message that you want the audience to
take away second step
start with your headline tell the
audience straight up what the forest is
what your message is
third step trim away all excess teacher
ask yourself
skroob Russkies is this sentence
necessary is this necessary is this word
necessary and with that hopefully we
wouldn't commit this error I as Mark
Twain said I don't have time to write a
short letter so I wrote a long one
instead so with that I'll pass it over
to Donna to talk about the third rule
confidence be confident be direct
so the GSB coaches us of the trades
confident as we stand confident and we
will now add on that by showing you how
to talk more confident for this part of
the presentation I need your help I need
you to please listen to two examples
from my teammates and help you decide
which one of them sounds more confident
you are for that plan Audrey music video
was so lovely to watch I just wanted to
say that Audrey's music video was so
lovely to watch easy ones to do I live
in it our first step is drop the web
just be used just it minimizes your
statement and can make you sound
offensive or give an apologetic it's
tough to get over this is go back to
your rescue
getting read through it identify way to
use just delete it delete the statement
and you'll see how much more powerful
the sound over time take that Pigman see
and transversing to your real-time
communication at that in case it is just
channel number for Mike and Mike and
remember just do it
the doctor is just just do it let's look
at another example
I know expert in this but for it a
suggestion for pitching word great bird
suggestion for pitching we're great
this was the easy one that drop the
qualifiers if you use qualifiers you
need gate the credibility of your own
statement at times we all have to give
observation or opinion that might turn
out wrong but if you start out by
pointing out why you're going to be
wrong before you said what's going to be
wrong you're just wasting words so in
the interest of time I'm going to speed
up a little bit attempt to get over the
qualifiers is remember you are already
qualified no matter where you go what
situation you will bring a unique
perspective that will add value to that
conversation as I said we have little
time so quickly to get the Q&A another
one to drop is I think probably use I
expect on convinced or I believe the tip
to get over it is keep calm and rephrase
they can see seconds breathing and then
say what you need to do the last one is
I can this is I want this one is much
more subtle but you can make a much more
powerful impression by using I won't it
gives you the opportunity to plan
identity independence and control camp
is passive
I won't is active the tip to get over
this is remember President Obama he said
yes we can remember yes you can but you
want
so for summarize in summary and remember
to be to keep itself all to keep it
brief and this
with that let's open it up for Q&A
[Music]